era tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fuori j
oggi siamo tornati su get mario il primo
episodio l'avevo fatto un po così perché
non sapevo bene che cosa si trattava ho
capito che per superare quel [ __ ]
punto di quella bandiera di merda
dovevo devo prendere per in corsa
praticamente però no no no che perfetto
mi sono ricordato del cloro ma cade ei
agivano sotto lo stesso noi donna mamma
mia ragazza un caso disperato vabbè
praticamente per passare quel punto
dovevo saltare doveva saltare oltre la
bandiera quella quella che prima non son
riuscito a superare è una volta che
riusciva a saltare sopra la bandiera
ammirate la gala bandiera fa vj e fanta
io questa qua la piazzerò sulla luna un
giorno è praticamente raga dovevo
saltare la la bandiera devo prendere più
in corsa praticamente adesso che sapevo
dove si trovano i trabocchetti e stata
abbastanza facile se ci riesco bene se
no va a quel paese tue la bandiera e
quel razzo di merda che ci esce allora
vai inter ago impossibile non so che
cosa devo fare regali non sono disperato
non so che cosa devo fare
cielo provate tutte devo mettere jetpack
non so che cazzo fare sennò che a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
e va beh non tanto ormai raga è una cosa
era cioè basta dai c'è ma perché io io
ho fatto anche il secondo episodio di
sta roba
c'è ma possa essere così stupido vabbè
e allora facciamo cerchiamo di fare i
seri per quel poco che mi è rimasto di
razionalità madonna è impossibile
[Musica]
si sa se ce l'ho fatta
ce lo fa barca [ __ ] non ci posso
credere non ci posso credere non ci
posso che quattro ore porca [ __ ]
ho preso la nutella cia del cielo adesso
la nutella bastardi l'ho presa devo devo
entrare qui dentro vero devo entrare qui
dentro nomi crollate se noi adesso
minchia lancio qualcosa che devo devo
andare tipo non lo so non posso entrare
dentro devo andare di qua non è qui
gioverà ok
ma porca top
astana porca [ __ ] porca [ __ ] lo
sapevo lo sapevo che dovevo entrare
nella bandiera porca [ __ ] lo sapevo
nostra due scelte ci avevo due 50 per
cento porca [ __ ] lo sapevo lo sapevo
cazzo ma per riprovarci c non lo so
cazzo non ci credo no no capraia
non è possibile non è possibile non ci
posso credere non ci posso credere non
ci credo non ci credo non ci credo non
ci posso croci può essere così
deficienti dai ma da porca [ __ ] volte
mica mi tirerei degli schiaffi da solo
ma porca [ __ ] ma si può essere più
dementi ma cazzo c'è ma non ci posso
credere sono riuscito a finirlo di nuovo
e poi sono ma porca [ __ ]
ecco vedi adesso non ci riesco più gatto
di merda
minchia ce l'ha fatta
che anzi a cazzo che ansia devo farmi 12
di tre di camomilla cristo c'è marca
[ __ ] c'è chi cazzo è inventato sto
gioco mi chiama cela un cuore cosa c'è
scritto
sì l'inter c'è la nutella a me basta ci
sia quella almeno c'è mi consolo cazzo
c'è raga ma dai ma si può fare delle
cose che cazzo successo che mi hanno
tirato un calcio nel culo cosa perfetto
vabbè bene siamo ancora all inizio
perfetto c'è un fungo perché c'è un
fungo devo prenderlo cosa no
non devo prendere il fungo fantastico
che cosa devo fare qui è una roba c'è
dove devo andare non ho capito la c'è il
fungo l'abbiamo capito devo saltare non
devo saltare dopo che cosa devo fare
che cos'è sta roba cioè devo forse raga
forse forse ho capito no ecco come non
detto [ __ ] devo riuscire a fare
una cosa non so neanche se ho capito
perché non è difficile già farla e
allora in teoria io ho pensato che
devo fare tipo così devo far uscire con
l'affare li puoi provare ad andare lì
sopra e scendere sperando che non
decolla se la ragazzo cos'è il ragga
rido per non piangere a questo punto che
cazzo sono morta un'altra volta
ok calmi pianissimo allora sì fantasmini
di merda facciamo nei fori ok ho paura
non lo so se quel fungo posso prenderlo
no ma john è diventato ma che cazzo no
se a posto allora devo devo niente
raga
io voglio voglio conoscere di persona lo
voglio conoscere ci sediamo
tranquillamente a un tavolo io è la
persona che ha creato questo gioco
voglio conoscerlo voglio sapere chi è
perché mi interessa capire che cazzo ma
no ma che cazzo ma che cosa stupida
vabbè allora non ci conviene neanche a
noi diventare enormi a questo punto
vado avanti senza
e va bene niente niente niente capitano
non la sto gioco proprio è neanche
descrivere una cosa senza senso
guardava dai che forse sucate tutti è
cosa devo fare solo saltare la tartaruga
perfetto devo tipo fare cos'è se ce l'ho
fatta
è uscito chi cazzo è quello in un
fantasmino super sayan niente lo sa lo
sapevo lo sapevo anche ma lo sapevo
anche niente raga niente niente niente
cioè io io veramente lasciate ogni
speranza voi capri the cat mario è
impossibile cena cosmo niente mi
dimentico e torno indietro mi dimentico
le cose poi non riesco più ad andare
avanti porca [ __ ]
c'è la mia tastiera vista da odiando
dopo questo episodio ma io studiando il
creatore di questo videogame molo
studiando veramente parecchio
e va beh veramente io non so che cosa
dire e cosa devo fare qui non posso devo
saltare prima ok no vedo bene che cos'è
ho saltato il peggio fantasma c'è la
bandiera devo pregare che non ci sia un
tranello in questo [ __ ] salto
solo questo forse prova a saltare da qua
così l'ho fatto eh sì vabbè ho preso la
bandiera fa vj è crollato il mondo vabbè
pazienza tanto riparto da qui è una cosa
veramente assurda
cioè io devo fare tipo così adesso ok
devo alternare perfetto ok allora prova
a fare come tipo così
ok se no è crollato anche il soffitto
fantastico allora devo ci provo che
perfetto mai vai a vedere
porca [ __ ] piano piano vai vai vai vai
adesso mi conto più cosa devo fare non
mi ricordo più non posso saltare perché
niente o niente porca [ __ ]
porca [ __ ] porca [ __ ] porca [ __ ]
guardate che calligrafia della madonna
c'è ma che cazzo è impossibile sto gioco
assurdo c'è veramente no si no
raga io ma perché perché perché ho fatto
un secondo episodio perché perché io ho
ascoltato voi che mi consigliava te
questo gioco
e poi ho fatto un secondo episodio di
questo gioco perché
[Musica]
si no
no ce l'aveva quasi fatta ce l'aveva
quasi fatta non ci credo ho capito
almeno ho capito che cosa devo fare già
un traguardo ed evo tipo saltare dico a
tornare indietro se crolla qualcos'altro
no perfetto ce l'ha mi stavo
dimenticando del cubo
mi è andata da dio c'è poteva andare
veramente male
ok ho trovato una stella c'è il fungo
non lo prendo lo prende lo prende il
fantasma super sayan nostro punto ok è
caduto devo devo salire qui perfetto che
non ci arrivo merda ragazze
adesso prima che riesca a rifarlo di
nuovo ci metterò delle ore vabbè ormai
raga sono rassegnato
invece ce l'ho fatta subito cosa devo
fare devo farlo cadere non ho capito
devo fare allora forse tipo devo fare
una roba
allora forse ho capito devo fare tipo no
ok esattamente non così ho capito anche
che cosa servono i capelli da super
sayan praticamente non ci poi non lo
puoi calpestare tutto qua ok piano piano
piano lo zero qua
ma porca [ __ ] c'è ma allora come
faccio
non ho capito sinceramente non l'ho
capita allora facciamo una cosa facciamo
una bellissima niente non facciamo un
cazzo
se ce l'ho fatta incredibile è un
ragazzo penso praticamente raku lo devo
veramente pregare di trovare la bandiera
devo pregare di farlo perché se non la
trovo ho paura di che cos'è questo punto
interrogativo paura ok è che cazzo non è
successo non sono morto perfetto ma era
quello che mi aspettavo
vi sono partite le palle a caso
ok che constato numeri fa devo riuscire
a saltare quel punto è impossibile
vabbè ci provo ma tanto so che muoiono
faccio anche un gradino tipo fare allora
aspettate un attimo a caso vai di caschi
e cazzo e impara che è impossibile
allora non dovevo prenderlo cosa fare lo
sapevo
vabbè ci provo all'ultimo tentativo
proprio se riesco a farlo ok ultimo
tentativo per questa puntata la chiudo
qui
provo a farlo filato da adesso in avanti
ok se se voi adesso chiudo il video
perché veramente è
ne ho abbastanza c'è che mario veramente
stressante vi giuro è stressante
ok devo pregare solo che sto deficiente
muoia nel modo giusto perché se muore
nel modo sbagliato io non ci arriva
dall'altra parte infatti mi sa che non
ci arrivo cos'è quella fare non lo
voglio prendere
ok ci prova no no ok mi sa che raga non
ci
no non ci credo che culo che culo
assurdo
ok ok ok non lo prendo perfetto no ok
bene raga bacula no no no no no no no no
no no no ma ragazzi basta per questo
episodio la chiudo qui non so quanto è
durato non me ne frega niente io non
vado avanti e quando mi sarò calmato il
prossimo episodio se lo faccio fatemi
sapere se volete che continui lo sa che
non di rete di no lo sa perché siete nei
maledetti però vabbè fatemelo comunque
sapere se volete che continui nel caso
il prossimo episodio mi prenderò una
punta azione di camomilla e me lo metto
qui di fianco perché l'acqua non aiuta
soltanto la camomilla
così almeno vado tranquillo cioè nel
senso nei momenti diciamo dove prendere
la tastiera alla lancia dei fuori dalla
finestra in quei momenti
posso provare a bere la camomilla per
calmarmi allora maledetto che mario
maledetti creatori di questo videogame
io chiudo qui l'episodio come al solito
la gas ei video vi è piaciuto lasciato
un commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come non i video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete ancora
city iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo in un
prossimo video bella ragazzi